[Music]
it's videos like this the home secretary
once removed from social media
believing in her words they glamorize
migrant crossings
this one appears to show a group of men
going from calais to dover posted on
tick tock
it's been watched more than eight
hundred thousand times
while similar posts have appeared on
other platforms advertising fake
passports
in a letter to social media companies
pretty patel wrote
posts which promote and even glamorize
these lethal crossings
are totally unacceptable they encourage
others to leave a safe european country
and put theirs and their family's life
at risk and are even used by people
smugglers
to promote their deadly business in the
hot weather that business is booming
these migrants were among nearly 600 who
attempted the crossing
in just three days this week while more
than 3 000
have reached these shores since the
start of the year nearly double
the number seen in the same period last
year the surgeon crossings has also seen
a record number of children arrive
here on the kent coast the local council
has a statutory responsibility to
accommodate them
but they say there are now so many
they'll soon no longer be able to do so
safely
and so they're now preparing to take
legal action against the home office
to ensure unaccompanied minors are sent
elsewhere in the country
the home office said it was grateful for
kent county council's contribution
and that it encourages more areas to do
their part as border force vessels
continue to patrol the coast
on a near daily basis but charities say
that strategy
isn't working and the letter to social
media companies is an attempt to pass
the buck
i think it's a badly designed attempt to
deflect the blame onto other people
let's be clear nobody is getting in a
dingy and coming across the channel
because of a tick tock video
they're coming across because they don't
see they've got any other options
in many cases the migrants travel in
overcrowded ribs
knowing full well they're risking their
lives hundreds of the boats now lie
abandoned in dover
underlining the scale of the issue i
don't think we're
going to see a complete halt to this at
least until such time as we can have a
proper
safe third country agreement with france
where people are instantly
returned to france where they will be
processed there
and until we have that i think we're
still going to have a problem here
in a statement facebook said it was
working with law enforcement agencies to
remove any content involving illegal
crossings
but it's clear that's only one part of a
complex picture
iva bennett sky news foxton